this is just a little moment when we  introduced mrs. price I really love it  it's my kind of you know homage to  Spielberg or I don't know why I kept  calling the Spielberg shot I'm sure he  knows but it some way I'm stealing from  something he does but we just always  called the Spielberg shot Spielberg shot  so you know we introduced her kind of  enigmatically mrs. price and then her  hand let's kind of old lady hand comes  up and it's a kind of a beautiful way to  introduce your character you haven't  seen it in 19 years  mrs. price  I try to come once every week sometimes  I admit I have neglected a week here in  there he's changed over the years I can  tell he's giving up it's hard to see he  thinks he was a mistake I'm not saying  he did good things he didn't those poor  people didn't deserve to die like that  so he's trying to make sense of who he  is and what y'all doing  [Music]